But the past is the past is up for discussion.
That's a pass is up for discussion.
Good.
Thrilled.
If somehow or another they were able to work it out where Jimmy Smith was at the
UFC,
we shall see.
That would be what I would like to say.
We shall see how that goes.
I would like to see that.
We will.
That's a big fuck up.
Yeah,
man.
It was,
um,
well let me say it like,
just a little background because I'll have people been asking me,
I haven't made any real public statements other than del Toro.
Hate her.
I just want to say,
yeah,
no,
never rebelled toward here.
Respect.
Yeah.
I enjoy watching it and like the fighters.
And I've always told everybody that you are the best out there.
Thank you so much.
Do an amazing job.
I really appreciate that.
Um,
number.
But yeah,
it's,
it's not a,
it's not a belt with a mean.
They were great to work with.
They were great about the,
the whole breakup thing.
Someone say it.
Yeah.
So what happened was I was,
I had a,
a deal with a,
with an option urine and 2018 was my option here.
And when I was in a Verona,
New York doing the Verona show,
my boss sat me down and he said,
we're not going to renew 2018 we want a different,
we wanted different deal.
And when they come to you and say,
we want a different deal,
what?
They want a downgrade,
it's never,
it's never your,
when your girlfriend comes to you and says,
I want to talk,
it's never,
I don't give enough blowjobs.
That's never,
that's never what,
they never say that it's always going to be a better girlfriend.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's always bad.
So yeah,
that was it.
When they were like,
uh,
we want to change the deal around,
I was like,
okay.
And they did make a like an honors Dev or to keep me,
they,
they really tried,
but they just,
they didn't make an offer that was,
there was worth me coming back and that,
that was pretty much a deal.
So it was kind of an amicable,
comparatively amicable.
It's fascinating to me that in the world of a mixed martial arts professional,
mixed martial arts,
there haven't been that many people that have done you.
What you and I both do,
this is a small handful of people.
You don't,
you're,
the weird thing is about our job really in it,
and I mean this from the bottom of my heart.
Um,
everybody thinks they've got a guy.
It's,
it's one of those jobs that everybody thinks they can do that they really go,
we'll just throw a fighter and then he'll be able to,
it.
I've seen,
I don't know how many of the unfit they want to do.
You know,
even locker room interviews aren't going to get next fight and do that.
And it's,
it's a job.
It's just,
it's really,
I mean it's,
it's one of those things where everybody thinks they can throw somebody in and
do it.
And I've seen,
I don't know how many try and it's,
it's tough.
You really have to work at it or having a knack for it.
It's not the kind of thing that,
you know,
it's almost like coaching.
I mean,
how many times you heard,
I've heard of great,
great Jujitsu guys,
like he's just not a great guy.
He's naturally really good.
He's not good at teaching it because Tim,
it just works and then you try it.
It doesn't work.
You know what I'm saying?
To her,
a great fighter isn't a great coach.
Some here,
a great fighters in,
it's a great broadcaster.
It just doesn't work that way.